SPEAKER: This is Android Tool
Time, Google AO edition where
we announced a preview of
the new Android Studio 3.0,
now available for download
in the Canary channel.
We decided to bump the
major version to 3.0, thanks
to the many new features
and some breaking
changes that we're
introducing in this release.
We've been listening
to user feedback
about adding more languages
support to the platform.
Something fun, concise, and
expressive, like Kotlin.
So we've decided to
bundle Kotlin support
with Android Studio
3.0, allowing developers
to immediately start
using it in their apps.
You can choose to enable Kotlin
in the new project wizard,
and the generated activities
will use it by default.
Or, when adding new
activities to your projects,
you can use the language
selector at the bottom
to switch between languages.
And finally, the convert Java
file to Kotlin file refactoring
will help when converting
your existing classes.
Android Studio 3.0 is based on
the 2017.1 branch of IntelliJ
IDEA, and includes
all the enhancements
from this, and the
previous stable release,
including parameter
hints for method
codes, semantic
highlighting, smart conflict
resolution and
syntax highlighting
in version control, and more.
To help developers bring Android
O features to their apps,
we're adding support
for front resources,
and adaptive icons in the IDE.
You can now create and
preview XML and binary fonts
in the fonts resource folder.
The Layout Editor also lets
you pick downloadable fonts
from the Google fonts
site for text views.
To create an adaptive
launcher icon for your app,
open the Asset Studio,
and select the foreground
and background images
that you'd like to use.
Of course, we're also including
O system images for the Android
emulator so you can test
your changes on the current O
developer preview build.
Coinciding with
Android Studio 3.0,
there are also big changes
in the build system.
We have built bytecode
transformations called Desugar
into the default toolchain,
enabling developers
to use Java 8 language features
in their code and libraries.
We support lambdas,
method references, default
and static interface methods,
and try-with-resources
on all API levels.
If you were previously using
Jack, which is now deprecated,
or some other bytecode
rewriter such as retrolambda,
migrating is as simple
as removing them
from your build files.
With the new Gradle plugin,
we are bringing performance
enhancements to
the build process,
such as dependency
resolution at execution time,
faster builds for projects
with a large number of modules,
and incremental dexing.
To support more fine-grain
dependency configuration,
including variant awareness
for library modules,
we had to introduce breaking
changes to our Gradle DSL.
So please refer to
the documentation
for migration steps.
To reduce the burden of setting
up and maintaining CI servers,
we are also launching
Google's Maven Repo as a place
where we distribute
Google's build artifacts.
At launch, we provide the
Android Support libraries,
and you can start using them
by adding the Maven Repo
URL to your Gradle files.
OK, let's talk about some more
updates in the IDE itself.
For debugging performance
problems with your apps,
we now ship the unified
Android profiler in-studio.
It's really a set of three
profilers-- for CPU, memory,
and network, shown on a single
timeline that also includes
various app events, such
as user inputs, rotations,
and activity changes.
By clicking on any of
the three profilers,
you can open the detailed view.
For CPU, this includes
a list of threads,
and a way to record and
explore method traces.
The memory view now shows
a more detailed breakdown
of where the memory
is allocated,
as well as lets you
track object allocations,
and dig into heap dumps.
The network tab, apart from
showing network activity
on a graph, includes request
and response information,
such as headers and
payloads for HTTP requests
that were made using one
of the supported clients.
For now, we support HTTP URL
connection, and recent versions
of Volley, and OkHttp.
Please note that when trying
out the Android profiler
on pre-O devices
and emulators, you
have to enable advanced
profiling in the run
configuration window in order
to see full information.
If you're writing C or
C++ code in another IDE,
or perhaps you're
using other tools,
such as game engine
toolkits, to create your APK,
you can now use the Android
studio native debugger with
your app.
Open the APK for debugging.
Attach the debug
symbols and sources,
and you will be able to
step through code just
as with an app
developed inside Studio.
Android Studio 3.0
is the first release
to support creation
of Instant Apps
from your Android projects.
There are two new module types--
Instant App and Feature.
Together with the new
refactoring system,
they help modularize your app.
The App Links Assistant helps
set up the necessary app links
support, while deploying an
app includes automatic device
provisioning for
running Instant Apps.
If you run into any problems
when testing Instant
App builds, we've
updated the APK analyzer
to open Instant App zip bundles.
But that's not all.
The text viewer now supports
loading ProGuard mapping files
to show removed
and retain nodes,
and can generate
ProGuard keep rules.
It also has an improved
user interface,
including filtering and search,
lets you explore method usages,
inspect bytecode
decompiled to smile format,
and supports multidex.
The Layout Editor and
the Layout Inspector
are both getting updates to make
iterating on layouts easier.
The editor includes better right
to left support, new constraint
layout features such
as chains and barriers,
and has a new
error panel showing
problems in your layouts--
for example, when you're
missing constraints.
If you need to pull files
from a device or emulator,
try out the Device File
Explorer, a much more
user-friendly way to browse
the remote file system
than using ADB, for example.
And finally, we have
exciting updates
in the Android emulator.
For the first time, we're
shipping emulator system images
which contain the full
Play Store, enabling
you to seamlessly test
integrations with other apps
without having to sideload APKs.
Placed around the
emulator also means
that you no longer have to
deal with outdated Google Play
services libraries, which will
automatically update, just
like on a real Android device.
Please note that
the Play emulator
images are signed
with release keys,
so you won't be able to
get elevated privileges.
If you require root access,
you can use the standard AOSP
emulator builds.
Other important
changes in the emulator
include OpenGL ES
3.0 compatibility,
a new bug reporting tool under
Emulator Help, Wi-Fi network
emulation, and a
proxy settings page.
For ware developers, we
added rotary input controls.
Whew.
As you can see, there
are a lot of new things
to play with in this
release of Android Studio.
Remember that we're doing these
previews to get your feedback,
and fix bugs that you
find in your projects.
You can use the new
Android issue tracker
to get in touch with us.
And be sure to follow Android
Studio on Twitter for updates.
[MUSIC PLAYING]